Hestia kommentiert Austin de Philosophie,
wenn ich es Ihnen verpfiff, bekommen Sie ein sehr scharf
geführtes Bescheidenheitsfeld. Wir leben in der
Industrie und auf Baustellen und Metropolen. Nachrichten.
Klimavandal. Meine Karikaturen
diszipliniert Tolkien Die Schlümpfe
Teekessel bejahend kratzbürstig Team
Falke der kohärente Zoologieprofessor von
der Harvard University Steven Pinker
zeigt den Bürgern Danke ja ich
habe rosa ehrlich im Tempo auf gibt
uns allen freies Geld das man für den
Briefkasten nicht alles aber doch sicher stoppt
die wichtigsten dinge wie leben für den
größten teil der geschichte der menschheit die lebenserwartung bei der
geburt betrug 30 jahre heute sind es weltweit 71
jahre und in den entwickelten ländern mehr als 80 jahre die
alphabetisierung heute
90 % der welt können den
größten teil der geschichte der menschheit lesen und schreiben  war ein
Privileg der wenigen Reichsten
, Frieden lesen und schreiben zu können. Die Welt
hat weniger Kriege als früher und weniger
PE  Menschen starben in Kriegen als früher
Sicherheit Wir sterben seltener
bei einem Flugzeugabsturz einem Autounfall einem
Arbeitsunfall Wir haben mehr
Stunden Freizeit I Fast alles,
was man im menschlichen Leben messen kann, ist
heute besser als je zuvor  Zu jeder Zeit in der
Geschichte sagt dct, es sei denn, Sie
bestellen besser die feierliche Sonnenfinsternis, die auf dem
letzten Boom alle 5.000 anderen HMDA-
Genres alle zum Tag bringen, und uns entwickeln unsere
Emissionen gevalt einen Schritt, der noch am Rande der
neuen
Südklarinettisten-Szene passt
Zunächst einmal wurde sie besser erwähnt.
Der Architekt von Helium muss das Gefühl haben, dass Kaffee
sehen kann, dass unsere Nation fertig werden kann
d
glücklicherweise Demenz ID Nun, es ist eine
Demonstration, dass der Fortschritt der
Menschheit stattgefunden hat, also ist es kein kommerzielles
Sprichwort, dass
ich daran glaube oder dass wir daran
glauben sollten, es ist, dass wir uns ansehen sollten
Wenn man sich die Fakten anschaut und die
Daten über die Zeit aufträgt, sieht man, dass
die Verbesserung real
ist, kommt sie deshalb so überraschend, weil das
Bild der Welt, das man vom
Journalismus bekommt, verzerrt sein muss, weil der
Journalismus über Dinge berichtet  das passiert
nichts was nicht passiert ein Land
im Krieg ist keine Nachricht ein Land im Frieden ist keine
Nachricht eine Schule die von Terroristen angegriffen wurde
ist eine Nachricht eine Schule die
nicht angegriffen wurde ist keine Nachricht und so weiter
und so lange  Gewalt ist nicht
vom Antlitz der Erde verschwunden
und ich glaube nicht, dass es jemals
Vorfälle geben wird, über die in den
Nachrichten berichtet wird, aber der relative Anteil von
Gewalttaten kann nicht in den Nachrichten erscheinen, und deshalb sind
wir uns dessen nicht bewusst  des Fortschritts, der
stattgefunden hat, also nur, wenn Sie sich die
Zahlen ansehen, wie viele Menschen jedes Jahr
durch Krieg sterben, wie viele Menschen ermordet werden,
wie viele Menschen an Krankheiten sterben, wie viele
Menschen arm sind, nur wenn Sie sich
die Zahlen ansehen, können Sie das sehen
Fortschritt sein  Denn der Journalismus kann
Ihnen niemals sagen, dass über berechtigte
Vibes von Muskel- und Yokums ängstlichen Erwähnungen in
Socken
- Weihnachtswerbung für Schmutz unter Miller,
aber in Glimmerplastik im Neuronenmetall
, das orange ist, sie haben nicht angenommen,
dass es eine Sonoran-Arterie war, die sie
um e klettern  ja also es ist kein widerspruch
zu sagen dass wir in
vielen dingen fortschritte gemacht haben und dass wir nicht in
utopien leben dass es immer noch unsere probleme gibt die
leute denken oft das es keinen
fortschritt geben kann weil mir so vieles
einfällt  Nun,
ja, es läuft jetzt viel schief,
aber gleichzeitig haben sich die Lebenserwartungen
verdoppelt und die Armut ist gesunken
und die Kriegstoten sind zurückgegangen. Es ist
kein Widerspruch zu sagen, dass wir
bei einigen Dingen Fortschritte gemacht haben, aber  Es
gibt noch Probleme Es wird
immer Probleme geben
Abbeville Eamon O'Meara Leitender
Techniker für neues Englisch Das Problem
ist, dass London
Vakuumraub Easton ist ein Vorkommnis in den Rätseln,
wette ich  ray me higgins on nine Rockstone
passiert mit mel Falk konfiguriert und
ein Verfahren kam herum, es ist kein Anti-
und sogar Effekt über sogar ausgeknockter
Weichheit. Nun, ich weiß nicht, ob
wir es schaffen werden, aber wir können es schaffen, wenn wir es schaffen
versuchen, es zu erledigen,
wenn wir das Vertrauen haben zu wissen, dass
wir Probleme in der Vergangenheit lösen, wir haben
jetzt Probleme, sie werden sich nicht selbst lösen,
wenn wir die Dinge einfach so laufen lassen, wie
sie jetzt laufen, könnten die Dinge schlimmer werden, aber wir tun es
nicht.  Wir müssen die aktuellen
Probleme nicht als Herausforderungen behandeln, bei denen
wir unseren Einfallsreichtum einsetzen müssen, um sie zu lösen, und
tatsächlich ging ein Teil der Fortschritte, die
wir bisher erzielt haben, auf
Kosten der Umwelt, denn
nur so kann man den Menschen verbessern  Wohlbefinden
entsteht durch Energie und Energiequellen, auf die
wir uns in der Vergangenheit verlassen haben, wie Kohle, wir sind
extrem umweltschädlich, aber dann
kann es einen Wechsel zu Energiequellen geben
, die weniger umweltschädlich sind, von Kohle zu Gas,
von Gas zu Wasserkraft und erneuerbaren Energien und
Kernenergie  nicht  haben
Treibhausgasemissionen und das ist ein Prozess, den
wir beschleunigen müssen, so wie in allen
wohlhabenden Ländern die Luftqualität sich
verbessert hat die Wasserqualität sich verbessert
hat bedrohte Arten
gerettet wurden, das müssen wir
auf die ganze Welt ausdehnen und  Es
ist einfacher, wenn eine
Gesellschaft wohlhabender ist, denn wenn Sie sehr arm sind,
brauchen Sie in erster Linie Strom,
und wenn Sie mit etwas Luftverschmutzung leben müssen, haben
Sie lieber Strom und
Luftverschmutzung als keinen Strom und keine
Luftverschmutzung, aber dann  Wenn die Gesellschaft
reich genug wird, um sich sowohl
Strom als auch saubere Luft leisten zu können, zahlen Sie
zusätzlich für die saubere Luft. Das ist ein Prozess
, den wir durch eine
Kombination aus Politik wie der Erhebung einer
Steuer auf Kohlenstoff und Technologie beschleunigen müssen, die
Technologien sind, die geben  uns mehr Energie
mit weniger Umweltverschmutzung sein Auto es
kämpft in Emission Cristianos Ich
sehe nie eine kanonenbewaffnete sehr stilvolle Demokratie
Ich vermisse deinen Ton c  oughs in the
spittoon Atacama vidalus ist eine glänzende Stagnation ist
fast eine Form das Energiegeiz Problem
dies am schnellsten atamanov am schnellsten wie
viele Anushka Lewis die öffentlichen Nukleasen
ist derzeit kein großes Problem
Atommüll wird vor Ort und in
Betonfässern in in gelagert  Auf den Parkplätzen von
Kernkraftwerken gab es nie
ein Problem. Irgendwann werden wir herausfinden,
wie wir es begraben können, aber unsere erste Priorität
sollte die Rettung des Planeten sein, dann können wir uns
Gedanken darüber machen, wo wir diese
Betonfässer hinstellen, wenn wir die Tiefsee
tief unter der Erde erschließen können  Minen, um sie zu lagern, wie
sie es beispielsweise in Finnland und an
anderen Orten tun, aber wir müssen uns an die Alternativen zur Kernkraft erinnern, die
viel mehr Abfallkohle erzeugen, die mit
den Nebenprodukten des Bergbaus mit den
Feinstaubpartikeln in der Luft enorm verschmutzt ist, damit wir das
können.  Sagen Sie nicht einfach, es gibt Abfall, ja,
es gibt Abfall, aber es gibt Abfall für
alles, sogar für Solar- und
Windenergie  0 40
50 Jahre, wenn die Solarmodule ersetzt werden müssen,
haben wir ein riesiges Problem, was
wir mit all den kaputten, veralteten
Solarmodulen machen, also gibt es nichts
umsonst, es gibt immer Abfall, die Frage
ist, was der am besten zu handhabende Abfall ist  die
Sierra de Sevilla und Esto Pasó Währung
Agni souveräne Ägäis liegt die
Schwester Hannah TCC Pelzhandel Norma Gibbs
bei Alicia Bow demokratisiert in einer
Kollokation für ein Gespräch mit Mason
Antacidum Aristoteles und einem Versuch,
uns umkehrbaren Kohlenstoff zu geben, wie
Richtek als Hochsommer-Finish schreibt
Vielleicht nicht, wie man Energie in
Newton bekommt, ruft die Sozialistin über Eva
Peron Omegan auf dem Grundstück auf, das über den Freegans-
Flugplatz über die Verstecke unter dem Flug von Neumann gestohlen wurde
Life Call Evan Hudson über Anton Zafir
Klettern auf eine Kollokation Lebensmittel bis zum
Kommen Wir wissen, dass die am stärksten verschmutzten
Orte der Erde in unserem sind  In armen
Ländern kochen ihre Leute drinnen mit
Dung und Holzkohle und Holz. Es gibt
enorme
Krankheiten und frühen Tod durch das Einatmen von
Kochrauch  über die Ansteckung mit
Cholera durch Trinkwasser in armen
Ländern machen sich die Menschen Sorgen darüber, dass
es wahr ist, dass in Bezug auf CO2-
Emissionen
reiche Länder unsere viel schlimmeren Schuldigen an Treibhausgasemissionen waren, weil ihre
Wirtschaft so viel besser ist,
aber da spricht es alta
stärker, um unsere Technologie so zu ändern, dass wir
, anstatt
reiche Länder arm zu machen, was nicht passieren wird
, anstatt den armen Ländern zu sagen, dass Sie
arm bleiben müssen,
was nicht passieren wird, unmoralisch wären,
wir müssen herausfinden, wie  um
die meiste Energie mit der geringsten Umweltverschmutzung zu erhalten,
und wir wissen, dass es viele
Technologien gibt, die dies tun können,
wenn sie mit Sonne und Wind kombiniert werden  Batteriespeicher
für die Nacht, wenn der Wind aufhört zu
wehen und wir die Batterietechnologie jetzt nicht haben,
aber wir sollten sie entwickeln
und sowohl die aktuelle als auch die nächste Generation von
Nukleartechnologie, kleine modulare
Reaktoren, die wie Düsentriebwerke in Massenproduktion hergestellt werden können
und noch weniger haben
Abfall und weniger Unfallgefahr, aber ich
glaube, dass wir die technologische Entwicklung beschleunigen sollten.
Wir wissen jetzt nicht,
welche Technologie am kostengünstigsten ist
, aber es waren immer Ideen
, die das Wirtschaftswachstum vorantreiben, die Vorstellung,
dass wir kein Wirtschaftswachstum haben können,
weil es nicht nachhaltig ist  weil
uns die Ressourcen ausgehen, ist falsch, weil wir
keine Ressourcen brauchen, wir brauchen Wege, um
unsere Häuser zu heizen und von einem
Ort zum anderen zu gelangen und uns Licht zu geben. Die
Ressourcen, die wir verwenden, hängen von der
aktuellen Technologie ab und die kann sich
ändern  mit Ideen So ging vor zwei Wochen
der Nobelpreis für Wirtschaftswissenschaften an
Paul Romer für seine Idee, die ich
in dem Buch unterstütze, dass es bei Wirtschaftswachstum nicht
um Re  Quellen, es geht um Ideen, und
dieser Ideenraum ist unendlich, wissen Sie,
sobald Buschmänner eine Außenstelle
in Seattle fragen, beginne ich mit der Erwähnung von
mindestens Isha Althea F. Beziehungen, dies ist
für unsere Industrie, Ashanti, kein kluges
Zeichen, dass es ihnen wahrscheinlich McGillis gut geht
wir wissen nicht, dass wir schlau genug sind
, um Probleme zu lösen, weil ich es nicht kann. ja
das ist kein Buch ist kein
Argument für Optimismus in dem Sinne, dass
garantiert alles klappt es funktioniert
nicht garantiert aber es
ist ein Argument dafür, was wir jetzt tun sollten,
wenn wir wollen, dass die Dinge funktionieren, und das
heißt, dass wir Wissen und Vernunft anwenden sollten, um
Probleme zu lösen
, die Menschen besser machen,
das sollte unser Ziel sein, ob die Gesetze
der Physik  und die Gesetze des Universums
werden es uns erlauben, wir werden es nicht wissen,
bis wir es versuchen, aber wenn es unsere einzige
Wahl wäre, würden wir nicht gehen, denn die Welt wird
nicht arm bleiben, sondern freiwillig ärmer werden,
und wir sollten es uns überlegen  heraus,
wie man gi macht  fünf leute das bestmögliche
leben die wenigste krankheit die geringste
armut die am wenigsten ignorante sünde
analphabetismus die geringste gewalt mit der
geringsten schädigung der umwelt sie
passieren für viertelgröße in american
chef this club of rome von Ernst cranium
axon on air
sucked Venga Vicky tiel  a - Valen Biscuit
Asthmakrise - Krise % v- Haus Casa
di ng Houston Bell Creamerien Fest
Gazettes Liste Parmesan Don DeLillo
Artikel und ein ehrlicher Fetisch fleischfreier
Anruf Essig Auto-Fan-Frauen auf
Drachen auf Kohlenstoffemissionen Anruf
allein in Cragen als Tat der Abgehärtete
Duvall the Union Squads – aber die Wahl
geht weiter wie wir oder Sie stellen
die gesamte zukünftige
Existenz der Menschheit in Frage. Ich meine, es ist diese
größere Frage, die Sie oder
Ihre Kinder nicht betrifft. Ja, ich meine, Ihre Kinder,
Ihre Enkelkinder werden eine haben  Ziemlich
unangenehmes Leben, aber aber aber es bedeutet,
dass innerhalb von Jahrzehnten ich meine, wenn Sie schauen, ist
es genau in der Mitte um das Mittelmeer herum,
ich meine, Sie suchen  In
zwanzig oder dreißig Jahren,
bevor es unmöglich sein wird, dort zu leben, ich meine,
es wird kein Wasser geben, Sie werden keine
Feldfrüchte mehr anbauen können, Sie wissen, dass die Menschen
aus Griechenland, aus
Teilen Süditaliens, aus Südportugal wegziehen müssen
das ist nicht nur in Bangladesch, das
wird uns in Europa betreffen.
Ich stimme sicherlich zu, dass wir uns
mit dem Problem des Klimawandels befassen müssen, aber
es ist wichtig, zwei Dinge nicht zu verwechseln,
eines davon ist, den Klimawandel zu
bewältigen, indem man das Ganze macht  Arme Welt
, das wird nicht passieren, die Menschen werden
nicht zustimmen, dass wir
keine totalitäre Weltregierung haben werden, die die
Menschen zwingt, mit dem Autofahren aufzuhören, besonders
in armen Ländern, wo sie zu
Recht sagen, dass es euch reichen
Ländern gut gefallen hat  energie seit
mehreren hundert jahren jetzt sind wir an der reihe
wir wollen uns bewegen können und
unsere wohnungen heizen und auch kühlen
wir werden sie nicht daran hindern
können dies zu tun und  Es ist wahr, dass wir
ohne die Möglichkeit einer Katastrophe nicht auf dem aktuellen Kurs bleiben können,
aber
die Alternative zum Aufrechterhalten der
aktuellen Technologie auf ihrem aktuellen
Kurs besteht darin, unsere Technologie
und unsere Politik zu verbessern, dh
Wege zu finden, den Menschen die Energie zu geben, die sie wollen
und Notwendigkeit ohne
Treibhausgasemissionen, die den Planeten bedrohen, so
dass der Vorschlag, dass
jeder zu einem einfacheren Lebensstil zurückkehren sollte,
außerordentlich unwahrscheinlich ist, wenn
dies die einzige Wahl ist, ja, wir
werden in große Schwierigkeiten geraten, aber was wir getan haben
in der Vergangenheit und was wir in Zukunft tun sollten,
ist, unseren Einfallsreichtum einzusetzen, um
erstens Anreize für Menschen zu schaffen, Energie zu sparen
und auf kohlenstoffarme Energie umzusteigen,
und zweitens
Technologien zu entwickeln, die es den Menschen ermöglichen,
Energie ohne Treibhausgasemissionen zu genießen,
und das ist  Viel wahrscheinlicher ist es
, dass Menschen sehr glücklich
sind, Energie zu haben, die kein
CO2 aussendet. Sie wollen kein CO2. Sie
wollen die Energie  gy und so für die
technologie gibt ihnen die energie
ohne co2, die dann eine viel größere
chance hat, von siebeneinhalb milliarden menschen adoptiert zu werden,
als ihnen zu sagen, dass
jeder zum lebensstil
der menschen zurückkehren muss, die derzeit in
indien verführt werden Physiotherapeuten also neckt  Die Emission hat
uns gefreut, einen Unterenergiebrunnen zu bringen
, seine Industrie startet die
Furanose, denn wenn Sie eine erstaunte
Kunst sind, wird ein Indien hinter dem
Staat definitiv eine Rolle spielen, weil
es eine Rolle bei der Festlegung eines Preises
für Kohlenstoff spielt  Das ist etwas
, was der Markt nicht alleine schaffen kann Es ist
eine Tragödie der Commons Es ist ein
Spiel mit öffentlichen Gütern Was die Ökonomen eine
negative Externalität nennen, nämlich jeder
profitiert von seiner Energie und aber die
Kosten werden auf den ganzen
Planeten verteilt
, um diese Situation zu korrigieren  Sie müssen
die Menschen für den Schaden bezahlen lassen, den
sie der Atmosphäre durch die Verbrennung von Kohlenstoff zufügen, und
eine Kohlenstoffsteuer ist der natürlichste Weg,
dies zu tun, also in Milliardenhöhe  Menschen
, die hunderte Male am Tag
Entscheidungen treffen, jede dieser Entscheidungen, wenn
sie für den Schaden bezahlen müssen, den sie
der Umwelt zufügen, ändern ihr
Verhalten und reduzieren jetzt die CO2-Menge, was natürlich
am effektivsten ist,
wenn sie Alternativen haben  Möglichkeiten
, Energie zu gewinnen, ohne die Kohlenstoffsteuer zu zahlen,
so dass das Gleichgewicht in
Richtung Erneuerbare, in Richtung Einsparung
hin zu alternativen Energiequellen kippt, und
der Staat spielt meines Erachtens eine zweite Rolle, so dass
einer von ihnen darin besteht, einen Preis für
Kohlenstoff festzusetzen, der andere darin, das zu fördern
Forschung an neuen Technologien, die
für einzelne Unternehmen einfach ein zu großes Risiko darstellen
, also die nächste Generation und
Kernbatteriespeicher für den intermittierenden
Strom aus Wind und Sonne. Es gibt
Unternehmen, die forschen, aber wir
wissen einfach, dass grundlegende
Grundlagenforschung etwas Gutes ist  für die
gesamte menschheit, aber nicht gut genug für
jedes einzelne unternehmen, dass sie
es tun, also ist die forschung eine weitere rolle
für die st  aß Indiana Heizung aus, aber Sie
wissen, was
das analoge Design Kernan dieser RAV
Ecclesia
Ameisen wiederfindet, die Crisanta ähnlich den
Baton II Optimisten in einer Volte
Aviras Optimist neben Material, das
uns am besten geschlagen hat, gebaut hat, ist erstklassig,
anständig, schön, romantisch  Natok bescheidene Klasse
ist Natalia und pessimistischer Bösewicht als SF-
Nation für hoffentlich einen Optimisten durchnässten
Sohn Andy Mason, der 2011 in Las Terrenas in CMS ausgestrahlt wurde
.  Nicht statistisch auf Dans
quälender Bande Möglichst
eine Schwesterhaut. Oh, genau das bin ich froh
, dass Sie das Lineal hier haben, denn das ist die
perfekte visuelle Erinnerung. Ja, die
mögliche Liste ist ein Begriff, den ich
von einem Hans Rosling ausgeliehen
habe  kein Sturm, das ist gut,
genannt Ischias, ja
nein, es ist sehr traurig, aber es ist genau richtig
, dass wir nicht messen müssen,
ob das Glas
halb voll oder halb leer ist, sondern zu singen, wie
viel Wasser in einem Glas ist  und wir
wissen aus Umfragen von Hans Rosling, dass sich die
Menschen
in ihrer Einschätzung der Welt irren, die Sie den
Menschen Fragen stellen, wie z
Hans Rosling
betonte, weil Schimpansen nach dem
Zufallsprinzip die pessimistischere
Antwort auswählen und sie sich irren, wissen sie nur, dass
es nicht so ist, dass das Glas halb leer
oder halb voll
ist  nur wissen, was die Fakten sind, und die
Menschen wissen nicht, was die Fakten sind, die
Menschen sind sich der Tatsache nicht bewusst, dass
Todesfälle und Kriege im Laufe der
Jahrzehnte zurückgegangen sind, dass extreme Armut zurückgegangen ist
, dass die Alphabetisierung zugenommen hat, dass
Infektionskrankheiten wie Malaria und
Lungenentzündung  Durchfall geht zurück, also liegen die
Leute einfach falsch, die
mit dem Sohn sprechen, sehen, wie weit sie
unsere Verwundeten nicht einmal bewegt hat, oder dies ist Darwin-
Torsion, diese leugnen es, ein plötzliches
Nichtsehen, in dem sie staubige, herumlungernde Pessimisten denken  Die MV, sie
sind Sie, Service und Shuffler, kamen nicht
auf EF, eine Stadt, ja, zusammen mit den
unvermeidlichen Verzerrungen der Nachrichten und des
Journalismus, die hauptsächlich über Ereignisse
statt über Trends und Daten berichten, gibt es
eine psychologische Tendenz zum Negativen, die
wir alle viel mehr sind  Sorgen über Verluste
und Gefahren als über Verbesserungen und
Gewinne, und das eröffnet einen Raum für
Gewinne, um auf den Markt zu kommen, und erinnert
uns an Gefahren, die wir möglicherweise
übersehen haben, und auch an Informationen  Das Unterrichtsleben
hat einen großen pessimistischen Teil seiner
Ideologie in der Geschichte des westlichen
Denkens. Zur gleichen Zeit, als es eine
Aufklärung gab, gab es auch eine Gegenaufklärung,
und sie gingen hin und
her, und große Teile unserer
Universitäten sind jetzt
unsere Leitartikelschreiber  Intellektuelle sind zutiefst
pessimistisch
Ich denke, irrationaler Pessimismus nach
den Ideen von Schopenhauer
und Heidegger und solchen Postmodernisten ist
eine große Sorte von Kulturpessimismus im
intellektuellen Leben, der sich oft nur
Daten, Fakten und Trends nicht bewusst ist, von denen
er nur Teil der
Religion ist  Die Intellektuellen, dass unsere
derzeitigen Institutionen
am Rande des Zusammenbruchs versagen, sind nicht nachhaltig
und das ist nur ein Dogma
unter vielen Intellektuellen, also der zweite
Grund, der tatsächlich mit den
Verzerrungen und dem Journalismus zusammenhängt, nämlich wenn
Sie Ihre Vorstellung vom Staat bekommen  der
Welt aus den Zeitungen wird es natürlich
im Pessimismus ungenau sein
Richtung Affinia zum
sicheren Ort eine Claire-Frau Varun über
Punkte Teilnehmerin Rania werfen Negativ war es
falsch Cynthia Erkenntnisse
Wissenschaft uns ist in Position okay und
wer Chanukka genau dort - Professor für
Psychologie die Kamelien Ana extrema
fallen krachend vertraut und verwaltet
almansi stehen weit weg, da wenn  Sie mochten
alle möglichen East
Val Arif iminium Christina nach China ist
wahr, dahab erwähnen Sie es für die
Gesellschaft stumm Titan Kmart Intro Santa
Paws über Smash Master Auktion von allen
stochastischen Asthma-Subventionen Geschäft
war nicht basteln ist es hier unangenehm ish
Stadt gut Option Geigen sind aufgehört  Wir sehen
uns Logan Einschnitt für höherherzige
Treffen Rebecca namens Stein China sichere
Pyramide Konami
das Geist-Körper-Problem und
löste unsere Spukgeschichte auf Philosophie andere eeeh ich
werde eine Gabel Alicia geblitzt, also waren
wir als nächstes an den Condor-Ohrhandwerkern vorbei,
nein, das wäre  eine kolossale
Irrationalität und stecke mein eigenes Leben für
den Zustand der Welt und ich glaube nicht, dass
ich das mache  Ich bin so egoistisch und ich kann es
beweisen, denn das Buch handelt nicht von
mir. Es hat 75 Grafiken, die zeigen, dass
die Todes- und Kriegsrate gesunken ist,
die extreme Armut gesunken ist, die
Alphabetisierung gestiegen ist, es geht nicht um
mich  über die oben geschätzten daten unter
mit dem anscheinenden benelli durchdachtes
design in flash der flug nach der schule
10 teufel susan es gibt keine möglichkeit, dass
du dir ein diagramm ansehen kannst, das
zeigt, dass die extreme
armut abnimmt, und wenn du ein schlechtes leben hattest, sag
gut  Extreme Armut nimmt zu, das
wäre halluzinierend, also nein, es ist keine
Funktion meiner Persönlichkeit, es ist
keine Funktion meiner Unkenntnis meines
eigenen persönlichen Glücks, es ist ein
Argument, das auf Fakten und Daten basiert und
diese Art von ad hominem  Gegenargument
ist nur intellektuell ungültig. Dies ist eine
Philosophie, die wir alle kennen, aber der Ad-
hominem-Irrtum, dass es kein
Gegenargument zu jemandem ist, zu sagen, dass
Sie dieses Persönlichkeitsmerkmal haben, Sie haben
dies wie die Geschichte  kein Argument
eine ziemliche Verbindung in den Gedanken
für Hestia Monica Santa CR alle
Komitees werden natürlich versuchen,
Boom, weil sie intellektuell das Gefühl haben,
dass dies die verschiedenen Teile
zu Marlon liebenswert macht, bestand Herr.  Heinz, man bekommt
Intellekt, wenn sie in den meisten
sind. Die meisten von ihnen sind wohlhabend und wohlhabend und
gesund und kommen aus privilegierten
Verhältnissen, also bin ich der Hamdi-Verband, ich bin
fertig, Convener, John Stuart Mill
Erin, und sie sind verkauft, aber sie
heißen Silber-Ali  Fazal, sie sind in einer
Reihe, sie haben oft Oktanten für
Zirkusdarbietungen, wenn sie sie über ihren Ehemann
verraten, wenn Andre Hoffman von
der Nam Granada über Schwule in Via spricht,
um es dem System zu beschreiben  versuchen, gut zu besetzen,
ja, ich denke, es gibt eine Tendenz
in unserer Zuschreibung von moralischer Ernsthaftigkeit
, das heißt, wir sehen alttestamentliche Propheten, wir
sehen Schwarzseher als ebenso ernsthaft wie tiefgründig und
moralisch und Menschen, die auf Verbesserungen hinweisen,
als so oberflächlich wie
Verkäufer als Propagandisten, so
denke ich  Wir haben diese Voreingenommenheit, und eine Reihe von
Leuten haben darauf hingewiesen, dass David Hume
darauf hingewiesen hat, dass Thomas Hobbes und
Hobbes sogar eine Theorie hatten,
um dies zu erklären. Er sagte, dass er im englischen
Wettbewerb des Lobes sagte  In Anlehnung an eine
Ehrfurcht vor der Antike für Männer, für Männer, die
mit einem Leben kämpfen, nicht mit einem Toten, mit
anderen Worten, wenn Sie Ihre
Gesellschaft kritisieren, ist dies eine Art,
Ihre Rivalen zu kritisieren, oder alle anderen zu kritisieren,
während die Menschen, die vor mehreren
hundert Jahren lebten  Ich meine, sie sind tot, sie sind
dir egal, und daher ist es
leicht, sich nach einem goldenen Zeitalter zu sehnen, um zu sagen, dass die
Dinge in der Vergangenheit besser waren,
weil sie nicht deine Rivalen sind
Vorher hatte sie in einem Müsli
Alicia Claire Frau erwähnt, in
Kaffee Cantar diejenigen auf einer Besorgung in ihren
eigenen verschachtelt und bestellte ihnen den Treibstoff Arliss
wirklich englischen Listennamen in der Mitte
sie irgendwie intellektuell und jeder Teil
klein wie in getan so Vitae
Maschine durch CF  na Kristen erwähnte
Fahrzeug erziehen auf Corinne die neuesten
sind eingeschüchtert von den Rocky
Mountain Aapke Hain koun in Rust Belt
Fish Place in der Gesellschaft schrecklich Körper VAR
cg r FD in Deutschland, als ob ich einige erwähnt hätte
Pflanzentier in allen Speicherlanden
digital Aapke Hain Kaun fin norok
in Franklinton Werte von der Polizei dann
hält es für Trost junger Mann, von dem das
Böse gut ist, dass die Unterstützung für Populismus
nicht in erster Linie von armen Leuten kommt,
zumindest in den Vereinigten Staaten, und ich
denke, das ist es  Auch in der europäischen
Bevölkerung fühlen sich viel mehr Menschen
kulturell als wirtschaftlich zurückgelassen. Die große
Unterstützung kommt von Menschen, die
gegen die politische Korrektheit sind, von den
ethnischen Mehrheiten, den Weißen in
den Vereinigten Staaten, die das Gefühl haben, dass
ihre Gesellschaft hat  schwule
Menschen und Frauen und Transgender und
Einwanderer bevorzugt und sie und
ihre Kultur irgendwie hinter sich gelassen haben und sie
die Vereinigten Staaten unterstützen, weil Donald Trump
nicht von den ärmsten Menschen stammte, sondern von der
Mittelschicht und den reicheren Menschen, die
kulturelle, kulturellere Ressentiments gegen das
Sabbatical hatten  in Brasilianer dachte Ivan
Affäre Dimension da und Änderung
ausgezählt, denken Sie an einen Präsidenten
Sowohl in Senado als auch in Vorurteilen sind sie weg. Verliert
es wirklich, die Coons zu negieren,
ist eine Nebensache Stevia, die verrückt gehackt wurde, dort
auf Flügen, Attika, Ditka-Gewölbe
, in 60.000 Erwähnungen, vergeben von
gevalt delict,
Sie wissen, wie ich ehrlich Alistair
E-Mails schicke und Crick's London  tatsächlich Millionen,
und
Brasilien und viele lateinamerikanische Länder
haben die weltweit höchsten Mordraten,
und es stimmt auch in den
Vereinigten Staaten
In den
wählte Richard Nixon 1968 für seine Kampagne für Recht
und Ordnung in gewissem Sinne
aus, dass er zu Recht darauf hinwies, dass die Kriminalität in Amerika
in den 1960er Jahren durch die Decke ging, und in
allen westlichen Ländern gab es eine enorme
Zunahme von Politikern, die davon profitieren
Das ist
jetzt natürlich so, und dann, beginnend in den
90er Jahren, gingen die Gewaltkriminalitätsraten in
Europa und in den Vereinigten Staaten zurück, was Donald
Trump falsch gesagt hat  Die Kriminalitätsraten waren
noch nie höher, aber selbst
wir sind sehr niedrig, aber weil die Menschen
sich der Tatsachen nicht bewusst sind, dass die
Kriminalität zurückgegangen ist, können sie empfänglich für
Forderungen von Politikern sein, dass
wir jetzt etwas gegen die steigende Kriminalität unternehmen müssen
Brasilien ist anders
Brasilien, tatsächlich sind einige Städte wie Rio de
Janeiro sehr gewalttätig, aber sie
haben ihre Gewaltrate gesenkt. Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, wie viele Menschen sich dessen bewusst sind
, aber Brasilien ist immer
noch viel höher als Europa
oder die USA, selbst wenn es heruntergekommen ist  Vereinigten Staaten eine bizarre mittlere
und Höhe in einigen Städten in Don Gaeta
stilvolle Angelegenheit, um diese eine eigene
Abteilung eines Freundes der lokalen
Küche Venedigs Imam al vida und Russland zu
überspringen und in sein Easton zu investieren, ist die
Gegenreaktion leicht ja, es ist nicht ungebrochen,
aber es  ist sehr bedeutend, also
ging es mit der Kriminalität in den 1960er Jahren hoch,
also ist keiner dieser Trends, wie ich schon sagte,
monoton, das geht immer in die
gleiche Richtung, immer nach oben  Immer unten
gibt es immer Wackeln und Blips,
manchmal gibt es große Spitzen, aber
im Großen und Ganzen waren die Trends
nicht überall positiv, das
wäre ein Wunder, das wäre Magie,
die nicht passieren kann,
und die Tatsache, dass es Minooka gibt,
nein  Wenn man sagt, dass die
Mordraten weltweit zurückgegangen sind und
einige Länder mehr Morde haben als
andere und die schlimmsten Länder sehr hohe Mordraten haben, ist
das alles kein Widerspruch, und
um den Fortschritt zu würdigen, muss man in der
Lage sein, quantitativ und nicht in Begriffen zu denken
von Perfektion oder Dystopie genau
ja, er hat eine Ausgabe von neun Kapital, sogar in
anständiger E-Mail. Klicken Sie auf,
um drei Santa's Capital
und Aviles Overages Capital von Tass
Capital zu beenden. Tomatensaison. Ich kann
sie auf dem Tisch lassen und die ungekochte
muslimische Dimension festlegen
das antiserum icon versteht in
finsterem polnisch mrs.  Anderson über gutes
Fasten Menschen sind
im Durchschnitt wieder glücklicher geworden nicht in jedem
Land der Schweiz sind die Menschen
in den letzten 20 Jahren glücklicher geworden,
aber hier und in der Schweiz ist
eines der glücklichsten Länder der Erde haben sie
es nicht sehr  Viel Platz zum
Ausgehen ist schon so ziemlich so glücklich, wie
Menschen gegeben werden können. Die menschliche Natur. Halten Sie die
Designer-Kadenz.
Wahrscheinlich ist es schwer vorstellbar, dass
alle die ganze Zeit nur ekstatisch sind.
Ich denke, unser Gehirn funktioniert einfach nicht so
, wie wir es einschätzen  aktuellen Situation
passen wir uns einigermaßen an und stellen
uns vor, was
alles schief gehen könnte, wir haben immer etwas, vor dem wir uns fürchten müssen,
aber trotzdem, dass
das nicht so interpretiert werden sollte, dass die
Verbesserung des Lebens der Menschen
sie dort nicht glücklicher macht  ist eine Theorie, die
früher als hedonisches Laufband bezeichnet wurde, dass Sie,
egal wie gut Ihr Leben ist,
nie glücklicher werden, weil Sie sich immer
so anpassen, dass Sie ständig auf einem sich
bewegenden Bürgersteig oder Ju gehen  So wie sich Ihre
Augen an das Licht oder die Dunkelheit anpassen,
passt sich nach dieser Theorie Ihr Glück an die Situation an, und egal
wie reich Sie sind, wie gut Ihr Leben ist,
Sie werden nie glücklicher. Wir wissen nicht,
dass das falsch ist, das ist zu stark Larsen
Unterlassung, dies sind Telekommunikationszitate, die Sie
gut kennen, sind [ __ ], Wodka, nie alle
Pfund, um sie in die Datenbank zu werfen, und Hamada
verwenden Bargeldeinnahmen, sie hatten jede globische
simlishe Energie de vivre, ein Signal, erotisches,
gruseliges Theater, Menschen könnten bald
Menschen nicht glücklicher sein als zuvor, obwohl
andere Bedingungen vorliegen  viel besser als
zuvor, aus zwei Hauptgründen Erstens
hängt menschliches Glück von
Erwartungen ab, nicht von objektiven Bedingungen,
wenn Sie bekommen, was Sie wollen, sind Sie glücklich, wenn
Sie etwas wollen, egal was passiert, und
Sie es nicht bekommen, sind Sie unzufrieden und
Das Problem ist, dass sich
die Erwartungen mit zunehmenden Bedingungen verbessern,
sodass wir heute viele Dinge
genießen, von denen die Menschen im Laufe der Geschichte geträumt haben,
aber wir fühlen uns nicht zufrieden,
weil wir es wollen  viel mehr, auf einer noch
tieferen Ebene, ist die grundlegende Reaktion des
menschlichen Geistes auf Leistung und
Vergnügen nicht Befriedigung, sondern sein Verlangen
nach mehr. Egal was wir erreichen,
wir sehnen uns einfach nach mehr, dass
es etwas Wahres daran gibt, aber wenn das auch so ist
Stark,
ja, wir wissen, dass Menschen in
reicheren Ländern glücklicher sind In
jedem Land sind reichere Menschen glücklicher
und in einer Mehrheit der Länder, für die
wir Daten haben, nimmt die Zufriedenheit im Laufe der Zeit
zu, so dass es einfach nicht
wahr ist, dass die Menschen in der Schweiz nicht
glücklicher sind als die Menschen  In Togo oder Benigne
oder Kongo sind die Menschen in der Schweiz
wirklich glücklicher, weil ihr Leben
jetzt besser ist. Natürlich
beschweren sich die Menschen in der Schweiz immer noch, dass sie immer noch
ängstlich sind, aber ihr Leben ist besser und
sie sagen, ihr Leben sei besser als die
Menschen in armen Ländern wie
Afghanistan  oder Länder im Krieg
wie Syrien, also denke ich, dass Sie
alle einen Punkt haben, der etwas Wahres hat, und das
war früher das Verständnis unter
Ökonomen  und Psychologen, aber das
wurde jetzt überarbeitet und wir haben festgestellt,
dass die alte Tretmühlen-Theorie nicht
wahr ist, dass wir den Meister nicht treffen
Villen in meiner
Jugend Tamales haben wir beim Kochen
dieses weißen Satiny betrogen, der mit ihm faulen
Togokahn-Eisenstaub ist, besonders Amorim und
Laster aus Finnland und unendlich all
unsere eigene Synthese, die offensichtlich
freundlicherweise Investor des in Disneyland erwähnten Systems ist, um
Personas guten Kuchen zu garnieren,
ja  Eine Sache wir die Geschichte über die
Schweiz manchmal dreht sich alles um
Schweden ist eine sehr urbane Legende, dass die
Raten in europäischen Ländern mit
hohem Grad an Sozialdemokratie hohe
Selbstmordraten haben, nicht wahr und in der
Schweiz habe ich eine Grafik im Buch
über die Selbstmordraten oder  Etwas, das
sie im vergangenen 19. Jahrhundert viel höher waren,
aber selbst dann ist Selbstmord
paradoxerweise kein perfekter
Indikator für Unh  Appiness Selbstmord Selbstmord
hat viel Mysteriöses
an sich. Teils ist es Unglück, teils
Impulsivität. Triffst du eine schnelle Entscheidung
und teils, wie einfach es ist,
Selbstmord zu begehen, wenn du viele Waffen
hast, wie in den Vereinigten Staaten, wenn du
Gift hast, wenn du  Ich habe ein Kohlengas aus einem
Ofen und die Selbstmordraten steigen, nur ist es
einfacher, es zu tun. Außerdem gibt es sogar die
Behauptung, dass es ein Paradoxon des Selbstmordglücks gibt,
dass es manchmal in glücklicheren
Ländern auch höhere Selbstmordraten gibt
, weil die Menschen sich
mit allen vergleichen  Sonst sagen sie, dass alle
anderen glücklich sind, was mit mir nicht stimmt,
während sie, wenn alle anderen
unglücklich sind, eher bereit sind zu akzeptieren,
dass das sowieso eine Theorie ist, aber die
Selbstmordraten in der Schweiz gehören sowieso nicht zu
den höchsten der Welt, eigentlich ziemlich
niedrige Steuern, die ich brauche  um uns die
Spekulationen über Crickley Smart zu führen, die Schwester
Ogin interesante Froglube Agnes Englisch
Hight Englisch Martin Ärzte Lizenznehmer
Ich bin ein historisches Timeline-Ventil an  Land
in schizont relativ von Mergen
Entfernung Minute Ich beendete das Englisch
bei Kearney Sonic und vermisse auch alle Ziegel aus
der Drehbuchdimension. Ja, der Grund, warum
ich in Bezug auf das Suizid-
Glück-Paradoxon sehr zögerlich war, war, dass es auf
einer Studie beruhte, die wir in sozialen Netzwerken kennengelernt haben
Wissenschaft, dass man nicht
vom allerersten Schritt an Schlüsse ziehen sollte, wenn
wir warten sollten, bis sich die ganze
Literatur ansammelt,
deshalb war ich etwas zögerlich gegenüber
dem Suizid-Glück-Paradoxon, aber wenn
es um Glück geht, während es
früher geglaubt wurde  dass wir uns einfach
mit allen anderen vergleichen und dass
die Menschen, wenn die Gesellschaft reicher wird, nicht
glücklicher sind, was sich als falsch herausstellte,
schien die frühe Studie darauf hinzudeuten,
aber jetzt, wo immer mehr Beweise
eintreffen, haben wir erkannt, dass das nicht stimmt
Reichere Länder sind glücklicher Menschen
in jedem Land, das reicher ist, sind
im Durchschnitt glücklicher Natürlich gibt es immer
noch ein
angeborenes Temperament, manche Menschen sind einfach
genetisch bedingt  Sie sind glücklicher als andere,
aber darüber hinaus
ändert Ihre objektive Lebensumstände wirklich Ihre
Zufriedenheit mit dem Leben.
Ben Menachem Ratsherr, unser Zelt war eine süße
Dimension, eine Leistung, die ganz
Emma mal Vida war, oder von wem die Froschabneigung
und die lockeren Zündhübe unaufhörlich
romantische Klassiker besuchen
Ryuuzan DDR-Verleiher haben ihren
Platz in unserem Kopf verloren, als wäre es ein
Spieler, den sie jedes Mal und
sie sind auf dem Svensson-Globus
in Vergessenheit geraten. Eine beste Kopie der Mamita des
Meeres für Alumni muss es vor
kurzem definitiv mit Philip Bloom aushalten  und
graben sich in das historische Fackelland ein, das
sie alle diese Aktionen ausgeführt haben,
und ehemaliger Condon erwähnte, dass
sie in seiner guten Kate erwähnte, dass ihr
transzendentaler Tom reichlich kommt,
sagt Hamish Melissa Foster, nein, Hannah und
hoch übersprangen die inneren trostlosen
Veröffentlichungs-Masalas, die Stars von
Carlson Canon Wide erhielten  Mohanty Matisse
informiert Wolf, ob die irische Kanone den
geschlagenen Colonel M  Atisse und Darts und
Sets Wir unterscheiden sicherlich
zwischen Religion in Bezug auf
Institutionen, rituelle Symbolik, Gemeinschaft
und den Glauben an Gott, insbesondere den Glauben,
dass die Moral von Gott kommen muss, dass
der einzige Grund, ein guter Mensch zu sein, die
Angst vor Bestrafung im Jenseits ist I
Ich glaube nicht, dass das besonders gesund ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass es Beweise dafür
gibt, dass es ein Leben nach dem Tod gibt, und es stimmt, dass
ich einer religiösen Person, die
durch den Glauben an ein Leben nach dem Tod getröstet ist, nicht sagen würde, dass
sie einen Verlust erlitten hat, von dem ich glaube, dass sie ein Familienmitglied verloren hat
Ich würde nicht sagen, oh, es gibt keine Beweise dafür,
dass es ein Leben nach dem Tod gibt, du
wirst dein totes Kind nicht im Himmel sehen. Ich
meine, ich werde einfach grausam sein, aber
andererseits, um ein allgemeines Argument zu machen, nein,
das glaube ich nicht  Menschen sollten
ihr Leben um das herum organisieren,
was in der kommenden Welt passieren wird. Ich
denke, sie sollten ihr Leben
um das herum organisieren, was in dieser Welt
passiert  Das Leben auf der Erde ist nur unbedeutend,
es ist nur ein verschwindend kleiner Bruchteil
unserer Existenz, was zum
Märtyrertod, zu Selbstmordattentätern führt, um
die Menschen zu zwingen,
Todesdrohung umzuwandeln, um sie
vor der ewigen Verdammnis zu retten, wie während
der Inquisition und der Religionskriege
und  es führt zu einer Vernachlässigung der
Möglichkeit, dass menschliches Mitgefühl, menschliches
Mitgefühl, menschlicher Einfallsreichtum das
Leben auf der Erde verbessern kann, jetzt kranke Menschen heilen
kann, Leben retten kann,
darauf sollte unsere moralische Energie gerichtet sein,
besonders jetzt, siehe Salman Khan
tut Muhammad, wenn Auguste Renoir
hier zu ihnen kommt  Toast auf das existentielle
Azoikum Ich fühle die Existenz ele auf
Stephens Erwähnung unseres Smart das
Überleben und wie in Verlusten katha Sterne
und soto plötzlich Körper Indien staubiges Leben
verschwand künstlerisches Fähnrich verschwand er wird
befreit Allison ist Initiative nach außen und
gibt oft spezifische Beleidigungen weiter
Rache und Verschwinden Meza
Wir fühlen uns wohl. Es gibt einige Existenzaspekte, die so
Teilaspekte des menschlichen Daseins sind, dass wir
Wir müssen uns damit auseinandersetzen, dass wir wirklich nicht
sterben werden, und wenn die Frage lautet, wie
wir den Glauben überwinden, dass wir
sterben werden, lautet die Antwort, dass wir ihn nicht überwinden sollten,
dass wir sterben werden, und wir
müssen unser Leben auf der Erde organisieren  in der
Erwartung, dass wir sterben werden, dazu
gehören Dinge wie sicherzustellen, dass
Sie das Leben, das Sie in den
Jahren, die Sie in ihnen haben, haben, in der
größtmöglichen Weise leben, es bedeutet,
auf andere Menschen auszudehnen, was Sie von sich selbst erwarten,
weil es möglich ist  nichts
Besonderes an mir, also muss ich das, was ich für
mich selbst will, auf dich und
alle anderen ausdehnen, die dazu gehören, dein Leben so zu gestalten oder zu
planen, dass du
das Beste aus der Zeit machst, die du hast,
um den Menschen, die dir wichtig sind, Liebe zu zeigen
Sie, dass Sie das
Leben anderer verbessern, dass Sie Spuren hinterlassen
, an die man sich erinnern wird, nachdem Sie das gelebt haben
, und ich denke
, dass es zu viel klügeren und vorteilhafteren Entscheidungen führt, sich mit der Tatsache auseinanderzusetzen, dass wir sterblich sind,
als gut zu denken
Wir müssen uns nicht um diese 70 oder
80 Jahre kümmern, es ist die Ewigkeit im Himmel
, die zählt
Koteletts tizzy über Lester Narr auf Koteletts
von der Tat n Süßigkeiten setzen eine
Leine von der Leine schaffen nahrhaft zu zielen
gegen alle anständigen erwähnten
Wendy schaffen eine Appellation vesanto
melina zum Marschall und Teilung fließend
gestaltet, so unter Dimension Phil
erwähnte Gefühle, wenn Sie Stephanie
Nana mögen  Existenz in dieser Initiative
nicht praktikabel Disney sie kommentieren
zweitens ja, aber glauben, dass
sie im Himmel Harfe spielen werden,
und für alle diese auch denke ich, dass
die Idee von Bullshit-Jobs
überdacht werden muss, die es unter
Intellektuellen unter Schriftstellern gibt  Unter
Professoren gibt es eine Art Verachtung und
Respektlosigkeit gegenüber Menschen, die Jobs machen
, die den Menschen das bieten  Das
Lebensnotwendige versorgt die Menschen mit dem Luxus
und den Freuden des Lebens. Vielleicht ist das mein
Hintergrund. Ich komme aus einer
Großfamilie kleiner Geschäftsleute. Mein Großvater stellte
Krawatten her. Mein Onkel hatte Autoteile verkauft. Mein
Vater verkaufte Kleidung, und ich denke,
ihr Intellektueller sollte darüber hinwegkommen
Idee, dass nur wenn du abstrakte
Gedanken hast oder elitäre Kunst zu deinem machst, du
etwas Wertvolles im Leben tust,
gegen Entropie, gegen
Unordnung, gegen Ausschweifung, gegen
Chaos, gegen Armut ankämpfst. Ich finde es
edel, dass Menschen, die in Unternehmen
arbeiten, Menschen Kleidung und Essen geben  und
Unterkunft und Unterhaltung zu einem Preis, den
sie sich leisten können,
tun etwas Wertvolles, und ich denke,
es ist eine Pathologie von Intellektuellen,
auf den Handel und die
Produktion von Dingen, die die Menschen brauchen, herabzublicken,
was nicht eine Frage der
Destillation von Klarinetten ist
Booster und Unmengen von mindestens 30 Stunden
Spieler, die
Remini-Brie nach denen gepredigt und Hindi-
Modelle gebaut haben  o endemisch die so kann
und Dokumentation Shlomos
die Schwester verschütten Philemon begrüßt die
genaue beschwichtigende Unschuld von Martini Lou
McGee, die auf der Missin
Samtknöchelunschuld Katya gefunden wurde, die er
Sara trieb, um dem englischen Detektiv Marty zu danken
guten Grund
ohne Beweise oder Logik so akzeptieren,
weil ihre konventionelle Weisheit,
weil ihr Dogma aus religiösem Glaubensbekenntnis,
ihr Dogma aus einem politischen oder
ideologischen Glaubensbekenntnis, der linke oder
rechte Flügel, aus Charisma, aus subjektiver
Gewissheit, fühlt sich für mich einfach richtig an
Intuition geht mit deinem Bauchgefühl  All dies
sind Quellen der Irrtumstäuschung, und der
einzige Weg, zu Überzeugungen zu gelangen, die
wahrscheinlich wahr sind, ist durch Vernunft und
Beweise. Gut, dass wir in einem
Philosophieprogramm sind, das diesen Idealen gewidmet ist,
die
derzeit außer Oklahoma in Mode sind
Unterdrückung Bhishmas eisiger heißer Barack
Obama und Anmeldeblätter lesen genau
den Flugplatz des fetten Onkels unmittelbar  ely on mit zu
Hause Emmanuel Macron Banane auf drei
eingefädelten kasachischen Fernsehredakteurin für Buntstifte in
meiner in der frühen amerikanischen Arztzelle unterrichtet zu
werden schwindelig zu sein UdSSR Havasu Nevada
Florida Freiwilliger Muhammad ein Hügel ist kein
schlechtes Spiel auf nein, ich glaube, sie reden
darüber, was ich  Ich spreche über und ich und
ich zitiere beide in dem Buch. Ich
weiß nicht, wie modisch es ist,
weil sie natürlich
gegen die Flut des Populismus ankämpfen, der eine
Bewegung der
Gegenaufklärung ist, die die Nation aufwertet oder  die Rasse oder
die ethnische Gruppe über der gesamten Menschheit,
die die Wissenschaft missachtet, wenn sie
unbequem ist, die sich an die Intuition appelliert,
im Gegensatz zu Logik und Vernunft, die
einen Führer als irgendwie
die Tugend und die Seele des Volkes verkörpert, im
Gegensatz zur Idee der Demokratie, wo  ein
Anführer ist nur ein vorübergehender Verwalter
mit bestimmten vorübergehenden Entscheidungsbefugnissen,
die von der Rechtsstaatlichkeit vorgeschrieben sind, so dass
die Werte der Aufklärung
meines Erachtens
bedroht sind. b  y dem Aufkommen bevölkerungsreicher und
auch anderer Bewegungen und so haben die
Leute, die sich für sie einsetzen,
viele Namen Ich fand
Aufklärung war ein gutes Etikett, aber
manchmal auch Kosmopolitismus genannt
die offene Gesellschaft von Karl Popper
manchmal Liberalismus oder klassischer
Liberalismus  obwohl dieser Begriff viele
Bedeutungen hat Humanismus mr.  Sabzian Tasya
Hobby Abu al-Hassan Liberale poetisch
zijn Mann kann keine Amerikaner Autos essen und
Emerson kam von gigan Rebellion
Frauen kamen von Knoten graben Analysten
erreichen ein Bremer Vincent kam von
immer Fundamentalismus und es ärgerte
mich  t Manabe oder durchnässt,
wenn wir Eclipse Autos Organisationen
von Wissenschaftlern haben, und sie werden in
Darts und Globin erfunden, neue Norton Darts und
Globin Don Bestäuber, großzügig, poetisch,
schöne Beilage Mohammed - Bienenpollen ist
nur oft Höhenunverträglichkeit von über
Colonel Anthony ma Maison de fehlende
Beilage  Toleranz und
Staunen Ich registrierte mich
zuerst mit einem diggin and liberals-
Projekt Ave und Eden zuerst auf der
Analysatorwelle
Sicher sehe ich die
Verbindung, denn egal, was Ihre
politischen Überzeugungen sind, Sie wollen immer
noch wissen, was  Wie die Realität funktioniert, und man
kann nicht wissen, wie die Realität funktioniert, ohne sie zu
messen, keiner von uns ist hellsichtig,
und wir haben keine Visionen von der Wahrheit,
wir müssen in die Welt gehen und
sehen, wie sie ist, und das bedeutet
Das Sammeln und Messen von Daten, was
Sie mit den Daten tun, hängt natürlich von
Ihren Werten ab, und hier
kommt der Humanismus in die Wissenschaft
, um die Welt zu beschreiben und zu erklären, und
sagt uns nicht, was wir
für Sie in Bezug auf die Welt tun sollten  brauchen
den Wert, dass der Mensch gedeiht, menschliches
Glück, menschliche Gesundheit, menschliches Leben und
das Leben anderer empfindungsfähiger
Kreaturen, nicht nur Menschen, sondern dass
dies die ultimative Moral ist
, dass diese Wissenschaft Ihnen keine
freie Reise gibt
ethik nur metaphysik zitronen oh
zotten
ja so ist es teilweise von
der austauschbarkeit der perspektiven,
dass von der unvoreingenommenheit, dass
an uns an mir nichts
besonderes ist im vergleich zu dir und das
th  Deshalb kann ich keinen Verhaltenskodex haben
, der sagt, was gut für mich ist, ist gut und
zur Hölle mit dir
zumindest nicht. Ich könnte es vielleicht, wenn ich der
Herrscher des Universums wäre,
aber niemand ist der Herrscher des Universums, muss
ich dich überzeugen  von einem Kodex, auf den
wir uns beide einigen, sobald Sie das tun, dass
Sie viel Moral bekommen, weil
viel Moral von Unparteilichkeit kommt,
vom kategorischen Imperativ, vom Schleier der
Unwissenheit, von der goldenen Regel, all
dies sind verschiedene Wege, um an
das heranzukommen  Die Idee, dass niemand einzigartig ist, Sie
wissen, dass unsere Interessen in unserem
Äquivalent liegen, es gibt auch eine
empirische Komponente, nämlich dass wir einfach
wissen, dass es auf bestimmte
Weise Menschen besser geht, wenn sie bestimmte
Verhaltenskodizes
annehmen  Da wäre es vielleicht gut
für mich, wenn ich stehlen und töten und
vergewaltigen könnte und alles tun könnte, was ich will, und
die Vorteile genießen könnte, aber es ist nicht so gut,
wenn alle anderen mir das antun könnten, und
deshalb müsste ich zustimmen,
Beschränkungen aufzuerlegen o  n meinem eigenen Verhalten im
Austausch gegen alle anderen
ihr Verhalten einzuschränken und wir
alle ein besseres Leben zu führen, ein Leben, dem wir
alle vorher zustimmen würden,
ist besser  das
Pflegeheim der Abend Gefühl
Politiker Razzia in dem Moment Anika war
eine College-Rechnung gemacht Psalmen er sagte auch,
er auch in Croissant seine Seltsamkeit brauche
viertausend mit dem Radio von der
Untersuchung über zehn Tarsus winzigen
Engvall bis Sargon von Clarence Geburt
ist nicht bekannt  offensichtlich schwereres Band,
absolut nicht, das ist kein westlicher
Chauvinismus. Es ist wahr, dass viele der
Ideen der
Aufklärung, die bis heute bestehen, von
einigen westlichen Denkern stammen, aber
Sie wissen, dass alle Ideen von irgendwoher kommen müssen,
die Tatsache, dass sie aus
dem Westen kamen  bedeutet nicht, dass sie gut
oder schlecht sind, und viele dieser Ideen stammen
aus anderen Teilen der Welt, auch heute noch
Ideen wie nicht  Gewalttätiger Widerstand als
Mittel zur Bewirkung sozialer Veränderungen kam
von Gandhi. Die Idee der
Versöhnung und wiederherstellenden Gerechtigkeit
im Gegensatz zu Bestrafung und Vergeltung,
die von Mandela und Tutu im
südlichen Afrika kam. Der Laie sammelt Ideen,
wenn es gute Ideen sind, egal
wo sie sind  kam aus und umgekehrt war der
Westen nie fest hinter der
Aufklärung, sobald die
Aufklärung aufkam, gab es die
Gegenaufklärung, es
gab Nationalismus, es gab romantischen
Militarismus,
es gab Faschismus, es gab Kommunismus
und totalitäre Schwesterländer,
all die sehr westliche Aufklärung
Im Westen sind zwei verschiedene Dinge, die
Renjie Zhang miterlebt hat, Cheviot
M&G Dimitra oder ihre Vorlage waren sogar
von dort Kweli hier, Cheviot ist
an und aus in Ihram Wallache Paris in de
verte hinterhältigen Männern, die versuchten,
den großen englischen Herrn zu beleidigen.  boom arme hören
orgel bauten projekte schwach ehrlich
angeline in dimension kerl stein wenig zu sein jesus
projekt sie alle schlagen
gut es passiert schon in gewissem
maße so nur als beispiel das
die welt vor mehr als 60 jahren so bekannt ist
die allgemeine erklärung der menschenrechte
Vor siebzig Jahren gab
es muslimische Länder und China und
christliche Länder im Westen und Westen, die sich
alle einig waren, dass Menschenrechte,
Menschenwürde, Bildung, das Recht auf
Gerechtigkeit universell sind, wo
es zu der Zeit gewesen sein könnte, als es
Angst gab  Wie können Sie alle
Länder der Welt dazu bringen, sich auf einen Kodex zu einigen?
Unmöglich, jeder hat seine eigene
Kultur, aber sie haben sich darauf geeinigt
, und erst vor einigen Jahren
schlugen die Vereinten Nationen die
Ziele für nachhaltige Entwicklung vor
, dh Ziele wie die Verringerung der Armut
Verbesserung des Zugangs zu sauberem Wasser
Umweltschutz
Frauenrechte Bildung und alle Länder der Welt
einigten sich
darauf und  das sind alles aufklärerische
Ideen, sie sind nicht, es gibt keine
Religion,
es gibt nichts über Gottes Gebote,
es gibt nichts über ein Leben nach dem Tod,
es gibt keine nationalistischen Gefühle, die es
nicht geben könnte, denn wenn Sie sagten, dass
ihr primäres moralisches Ziel darin besteht, zu zeigen, dass
die Vereinigten Staaten ein  leuchtende Stadt auf
einem Hügel oder das Leuchtfeuer für die Menschheit,
vielleicht würden die Amerikaner dem zustimmen
, aber Sie kennen Indien nicht und
Japan nicht und Frankreich nicht und die Schweiz nicht.
Tatsächlich gibt es einen natürlichen Prozess,
bei dem Sie sobald die
Zustimmung verschiedener Menschen einholen müssen  Dann bleiben viele der
besonderen ästhetischen exzentrischen rassistischen
religiösen Moralvorstellungen auf der Strecke,
weil andere Menschen ihnen nicht
zustimmen werden. Jetzt könnte es eine Angst geben,
wenn Sie zur gesamten
Menschheit gehen müssen, wird nichts mehr übrig
sein  ein kleinster gemeinsamer Nenner und
es wird keine Moral geben, aber wir wissen,
dass das nicht wahr ist, wegen der Ziele für nachhaltige
Entwicklung der Allgemeinen Erklärung
der Menschenrechte, da wir alle sind  l
Menschen, wir sind alle Homo sapiens, das heißt
, wir haben Dinge gemeinsam, wir
leben lieber, als dass wir sterben, wir sind lieber
gesund, sogar krank, die lieber
gebildet als unwissend sind, wir haben lieber etwas zu
essen, als hungrig zu sein.  Ich bin lieber sicher
als in Gefahr usw. usw. Das gibt
Ihnen eine sehr reiche Moral, auf die sich alle
Menschen einigen werden, wenn sie gezwungen sind,
sich auf etwas zu einigen
Al Cetacean Darwin
isness Hirsch will keine Taschen und das
Überleben der Stärksten verstehen und eine Limousine,
die Tore besucht, schickt einen indischen
Dolchschaft auf Tarzan z-9, der Mensch wird am
häufigsten gefressen, Pflanzenfresser, und
ich werde auch die verschwundene Albany Nana
Gesellschaft gut mitbringen  Nein, denn der
Humanismus unterscheidet sich sehr von der
Ideologie, die manchmal als
Sozialdarwinismus bezeichnet wird, obwohl er nichts mit Darwin zu tun hatte
, war es wirklich eher
Herbert Spencer, der ihn vorschlug, bevor
Darwin überhaupt schrieb  Für Ihre Spezies, aber die
Idee, dass es gut ist, der Natur
ihren Lauf zu lassen und diese Stärkeren und
Stärksten die Schwächsten verdrängen zu lassen, ist
das Gegenteil von Humanismus
, der besagt, dass jedem bewussten Wesen, das
die Fähigkeit zum Leiden hat, Möglichkeiten gegeben werden sollten, sich
zu entfalten  und nicht zu
leiden
, so funktioniert die Evolution nicht,
aber so ist zumindest eine Art Homo
sapiens mit unseren großen Gehirnen,
mit unserer Fähigkeit, darüber nachzudenken, wie wir
leben wollen, im Gegensatz dazu, wie die Evolution,
die sich selbst überlassen wird, uns zum Leben bringen wird  Wir
können daher
aufgrund unserer teilweise großen Gehirne Systeme entwickeln
, die sich sehr von dem unterscheiden, was die Natur
tun würde, wenn sie sich selbst überlassene
Lösungen des digitalen Heims zur
Unterdrückung des Allgemeinwissens in
etwas tun würde, das uns irgendwie zu einem
unanständigen Unkraut macht  Jeden Tag
hören wir heute nach dem Engländer über die Gesellschaft die Ionen in der
zweiten Saite und führen den
Namen Andy Hunt auf der führenden Null an  In mit Snowdens
Route zu mir in die Zelle, speziell
für die Verbindung mit dem Privaten. Ich würde Fatah
im prasanta Byzantine East Zoo
fühlen, aber das Digitale ist das einzige,
das die Signatur darauf entfernt. Nun, es ist ein Buch, das
lang genug ist, und ich widerspreche auch  es ist
Mode in den Medien, die
sozialen Medien für alles verantwortlich zu machen. Ich denke, es ist
oberflächlich.
Ich denke, wenn Sie ein neues Medium sehen,
wurde es immer für alle sozialen Probleme verantwortlich gemacht, als es eingeführt wurde. Das galt
für Print, es gilt für Romane  Das
galt für das Radio wie für das Fernsehen, und
es ist einfach zu einfach für Intellektuelle zu
sagen, welche neue Technologie ich
kenne, die meine Kinder benutzen, aber ich nicht
, deshalb haben wir all unsere Probleme,
also gibt es natürlich einige  Neue
Probleme, die durch soziale Medien eingeführt werden, aber
es ist nicht das. Ich denke,
es ist oberflächlich. Es ist eine Mode,
alles in
den sozialen Medien zu
beschuldigen  Sollte der trashige Panzer
und der Artie Lewis zustehen, da
seine Mittel noch nie dieses
Programm beendet haben, verpasse Ophelias Kolonie
ja kein Problem, so dass die
Tatsache, dass dies ein wichtiger
Teil des Konzepts des Fortschritts ist, die Tatsache, dass die
Dinge  besser zu werden ist nicht dasselbe wie die
Dinge von selbst besser zu werden Menschen
verwirren die, die sie nichts miteinander zu tun
haben und natürlich nicht der
einzige Grund, warum die Dinge besser werden, ist
, dass wir Wege finden,
das Problem zu lösen und das Problem zu lösen  Verschiedene
Probleme der sozialen Medien und der digitalen
Medien im Allgemeinen müssen auf
unterschiedliche Weise gelöst werden,
und Menschen, die sie gemeinsam
betreiben, müssen Wege finden, Konventionen
der Faktenprüfung und Wahrheitssuche
gegen die Welle der gefälschten Nachrichten wiederherzustellen, die
vom Problem getrennt sind  wie wir dafür
sorgen, dass wir miteinander interagieren
und uns nicht in unseren Bildschirmen verlieren, wie
wir verhindern, dass zu viel von unserem Leben
von der Bildschirmzeit verbraucht wird und
Üben Sie Selbstbeherrschung aus, Weisheit, Gleichgewicht, dies
sind separate Probleme, und für jedes müssen
wir darüber nachdenken, wie wir die
Vorteile der neuen Technologie nutzen und
gleichzeitig die Nachteile minimieren können.
19. November
wichtig nett von nylon zum
kommen lassen das ist was das ist eine möglichkeit
und ich versuche die dinge zu relativieren ich
sorge dafür dass ich zeit habe die
natur zu genießen freunde zu genießen mein
familienleben zu genießen ich wenn ich schreibe zum
beispiel ich  Bewältigen Sie das Problem der
Ablenkung, indem Sie meine E-Mail
für mehrere Stunden ausschalten, während ich schreibe. Ich erlaube keine
Benachrichtigungen, weder auf meinem
Smartphone noch auf meinem Computer
Funktion der Technologie, aber Sie können
es ausschalten, und deshalb schalte ich es aus. Jeder
sollte es ausschalten. Benachrichtigungen sind
eine dumme Funktion, die normalerweise
einfach ausgeschaltet
werden sollte  usty verlieren inmitten von Donna
Deegan ein Mann Probleme rook jeder Müll
haben ein hohes de león's das Problem Sultan
Wien Zürich Valen ein Breloom abgesetzt
und Armstrong Foreman's Arlen jeder
peidong Kommission's hatte Jesus an welchen
Ort nicht gedacht in vielen
Dank danke
[Musik]
dir